Texas Attorney General Ken Paxton and
another state leader who is supporting
Texas tonight South Dakota governor
Christine Nome good to see you both uh
Governor gome first of all thank you and
thanks to all the other Republican
Governors and frankly uh if Democratic
Governors were even being honest this
problem has become so massive for them
they should join in supporting you as
well absolutely every single one of them
should join us this is about our
constitution this is about us standing
United the 13 Original Colonies would
have never signed uh the Constitution or
ratified it if they didn't know that
they didn't have the protections to
defend themselves and so that's really
what this is all about I'm going to be
at the Border tomorrow I'm going to be
there to tell the Texas National Guard
to tell those border patrol agents those
folks that are in very difficult
situations in the public administration
within the state of Texas that we're not
only with them that we have continued to
be with them for the last several years
South Dakota has deployed our National
Guard to support them and stand
alongside them three separate times over
the last several years and we're going
to continue to do that a lot of people
talk and a lot of people criticize we
take action and right now I'm so proud
of what Texas is doing to defend itself
we'll be right there beside him we'll do
everything we can to make sure this
Invasion stops are you willing to send
uh Guard from from your state
Governor I already have three times U my
even my Lakota helicopters have been
down there conducting surveillance uh so
they absolutely are I am willing to send
National Guard down there to stand along
side I want it to be different
Arrangements this time if we're going to
enforce Texas law and if I'm going to
have the ability to use these soldiers
in a way that's effective that'll be
absolutely fantastic they have enjoyed
partner partnering with the Texas
National Guard in the past and I'll tell
you one thing Sean that is uh that is
interesting to me there's nobody that
supports Joe Biden's policies nobody in
this country the public doesn't support
it these border patrol agents don't
support it if you talk to anyone in ice
that's down there on the ground that's
seen this war zone they don't they don't
support what what he is doing 6 million
people have come into this country
illegally it is an invasion it is a war
zone in humanitary it is it is it's an
inhumane situation and uh it is
definitely uh one of those instances
where we need to stand up and defend our
state rights and this decision that came
out of the Supreme Court it did not say
uh that Texas couldn't defend itself it
said that they could take down the razor
wire but did not declare that Texas
could not defend itself and I believe
that still protects our state rights and
that we can certainly take action the
only way Joe Biden would be able to stop
the Texas National Guard from from
taking action is he would have to act
activate them under title 10 and
federally put them on active duty status
to keep them from engaging and being
under their commander-in-chief Governor
Greg Abbott uh it'll be interesting to
see what Joe Biden does here because he
is making very poor decisions destroying
our country and all the power of our
constitution stands with the states let
me go to you Ken Paxton I'll go to these
FBI luminaries I mean two 10 former FBI
Executives uh even those that oversaw
the FBI's intelligence counterterrorism
criminal and training operations they
are saying that that the US has never s
suffered an invasion of the Homeland uh
and yet one is unfolding now uh talking
about military age foreigners now what's
going to happen Joe Biden seems to be
giving deadline after deadline is he
threatening for federal troops to
confront guard troops in Texas is that
is that where he's headed here do he
want to showdown in
Texas look first of all thank you to
governor gome and the rest of the
governor for standing with us I think
this is not just a Texas issue now it's
a it's a national issue and as far as
the this terrorist threat I've been
worried about this it's chilling to hear
the report that John Solomon gave and
how that could potentially affect my
state and really affect the entire
country long after Joe Biden is gone
we're going to be dealing with potential
terrorist threats as far as a showdown I
don't know what Joe Biden's going to do
so far it seems like every decision he's
made has been a bad decision for our
country he is cooperating not just
cooperating but he's literally in
partnership with these cartels in the
old days they used to come and try to
hide and run away from border patrol Joe
Biden's cut a deal somehow where these
cartels transport people directly to the
border patrol and then they move them
around the country so we're in a
terrible situation nothing like this
country has ever seen before and I fear
the consequences of Joe Biden's
decisions for the next years well he's
the one that's not upholding the law
this Supreme Court decision uh as
Governor gome pointed out there are a
lot of areas where Texas is free to
continue to put up wire they don't have
to allow this to happen but it's it's
beginning to look like that Joe Biden is
basically you know drawing a Line in the
Sand and he's saying that you know the
feds are going to come marching in into
Texas and rip down your razor wire and
Governor Abbott saying we're just going
to put it right back up
again look I think I support the
governor he's going to stand I I talked
to him today for for a little while and
we talked about this very issue and I
guarantee you he's going to stand strong
he'll keep putting razor wire up we'll
keep blocking the Border we'll keep
doing everything that we need to do to
protect our state despite the fact that
this ruling this Supreme Court ruling
was so wrong and has such a detrimental
effect on our state and our
country yeah I can't believe it anyway
we really appreciate your time thank you
Governor Paxton and Governor gome hey
Sean Hannity here hey click here to
subscribe to Fox News YouTube page and
catch our hottest interviews and most
compelling analysis you will not get it
anywhere
else